hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the unreal air glasses a
huge thank you to enreal for sponsoring
this video Let's unbox them and check
them out so I already opened up the
little gift box that they gave me and it
came with this awesome t-shirt like look
at this this is super cool I also like
this has a little QR code here I have a
feeling that when I put these glasses on
this might do something cool but for now
we're gonna have to unbox before we test
this out all right here's the Box we
also have a couple accessories this is
just a lightning to digital AV so we're
going to be using that for the iPhone
and this is the unreal adapter but we're
gonna open up the glasses first
[Music]
oh they come in a nice little carrying
case of everything
look at that these are so small too
whoa look at these like these just look
like some basic sunglasses like oh are
you going to the beach are you hanging
out no I'm in the metaverse okay I can't
wait to actually test this out because
these already feel like a super high
quality like they look like normal
glasses and just even putting these on
like this is comfortable there's like a
little nose Bridge so it doesn't feel
like heavy on my head I feel like every
time I'm in sort of a I guess a virtual
environment any type of headset it's
always so heavy it's uncomfortable these
just feel like I'm wearing a pair of
sunglasses so here's the glasses you can
see we have the little displays kind of
built in right there you can also adjust
these if need be
this is I really like this traveling
case too I'm about hop on a flight after
this I'm not gonna lie these are coming
with me all right what have get ready to
see unreal air we've got to activate my
glasses again the QR code and download
the nebula app so they did provide me a
phone that already has some of these
things installed and this is the nebula
app so this is basically our eyes into
the nebula air so I'm gonna get this all
set up and we're gonna test it out I'm
so excited because this looks like so
much fun here's the unreal adapter let's
open this up
[Music]
there's some more things in the Box
so inside the glasses case we actually
have our charging cable which is USBC
and then Inside the Box we also have
some glasses cover we also have a few
little nose Bridge pieces and another
little adapter for your glasses here if
you have prescriptions here we have the
adjustable Temple so we're able to
adjust this depending upon the size of
your head and we also have the
microphone our on and off switch the
brightness button and the spatial sound
speaker this is actually a light Shield
so this blocks all of the light from
coming in so you do need to be careful
when you put this on because you're not
going to actually be able to see
anything except what is happening inside
of your glasses so here is a USBC cable
so this actually isn't a charging cable
so this isn't designed to charge because
you don't actually need to charge these
glasses and this is a very specific
cable to the unreal air glasses so if
you do need a replacement you do have to
contact them because you have to use the
specific one that was provided with the
glasses and real air has a 46 degree
field of view and 49 pixels per degree
which is pretty close to retina level
display this is roughly double the
resolution of regular VR glasses now
this device offers a three dof head
tracking system with high quality
Imaging with high color performance it
has two 1080p full HD Sony micro OLED
displays which is equivalent to 201 inch
virtual screens so basically you'll have
it IMAX in your pocket and on your face
the audio is also pretty impressive it
has super linear speakers a base
enhancement algorithm as well as a dual
microphone array omnidirectional mems
microphone and noise cancellation
capabilities to create a cinema-like
audio visual experience and real air
glasses help users make their first step
forward into the metaverse with nebula
this is unreal's 3D operating
environment and there are multi-mega
sized virtual screens in a 3D spatial
environment with ar native content like
the AR cycle link app for smart Fitness
this allows users to enjoy stationary
cycling in an immersive Scenic setting
there'll be lots of new and ongoing
Surprises with upgrades and expansions
as nrel is continuously unveiling more
AR oriented content and AR experiences
to build out their entire AR ecosystem
now also as an iPhone user and rule for
Apple users will allow you to use the
mirror mode with the unreal iPhone
dongle so you can view your iPhone apps
on 130 inch HD mobile display at 60
frames per second and real is really
great for gamers movie lovers and AI
enthusiasts now in mirror mode you'll be
able to game on a 130 inch gaming screen
which is pretty impressive it also
supports cloud gaming not just on the
iPhone but also on Android steam deck
switch Xbox and even PlayStation in AR
mode you'll have a 200 inch gaming
screen and this will work on most mid to
high-end Android phones this is perfect
for Xbox cloud gaming now for movies you
can watch your favorite content from
YouTube Netflix Hulu Disney plus and
even more more on a 200 full HD IMAX
viewing experience you can also view
YouTube AR there's spatial browsing so
you can take your web browsing to a
whole different experience level you can
also teleport into virtual models of
Real World and places and connect with
people all around the world you can
watch existing content and you can even
cycle around the world
so fun time to try this out okay so the
USBC that you want to plug in is right
here in the
little earpiece oh man this is
surprisingly comfortable these actually
look really good okay I've plugged in my
glasses it's saying allow nebula to
access yes let's do it keep the glasses
the theater is being updated it's being
updated this is so exciting oh
like I see right now what my phone is
seeing Oh my God I'm taking these on my
flight tonight yeah I can see you I see
everything this right here is what the
future is like this is this setup
something small or oh my God whoa what
the heck you don't see this you don't
see this well oh my God the whole ever
everything look at this my camera is
normally there my phone is my controller
I get to Point this around I wish you
guys could see what I'm seeing this is
unfair this is unfair this is like
somebody who is experiencing virtual
reality for the first time that I've
I've been in it before but this is a
whole different experience okay aim at
an object with a laser and I click the
touch
it's no secret that I was not the best
student in high school so if I would
have had this I would have been
listening to my jams and I would have
been cheating up a storm I don't condone
that but
how do I show you guys what I'm seeing I
don't even like I can't even tell you
how cool this is like this is so
so sad for you I'm popping balloons
right now dude this is
I'm gonna look like such a loser on the
plane
[Music]
so there's the light blockers because
right now I can see everything like I
can still see through these glasses but
if I put these on this is like a whole
new experience because I don't see
anything else like I don't see through
okay so now I want to try out the
mirroring from the iPhone this is the
unreal adapter so this little part
allows you to use HDMI in but this of
course is something I think that we've
all seen if we're Apple users so this is
just gonna slide right in like that and
then we're gonna attach this to our
phone
now we're going to plug this
into here
my iPhone has appeared before my eyes my
iPhone is floating in front of my face
they talked about gaming and why I think
this is gonna be awesome is because I I
always want to lay down in game so I can
connect this to my Xbox and I'll be able
to lay down and play video games because
I'll be able to see it right there in
front of my face because like wherever I
am it it appears
oh
shoot the one thing that I am very
impressed with is how light this is I
feel like I could wear this for a pretty
long amount of time without it feeling
uncomfortable I like these little nose
pads they feel very comfortable as well
the display quality is it's impressive
like it seems like I If you were to go
up to a big screen TV and put your face
super close to it yet be able to focus
on the whole screen
like that's what it looks like it's
Crystal Clear I I just don't even know
what to say like I'm so impressed by it
like this is a surprise to me because I
thought it was going to be cool but like
my expectation was like yeah cool this
looks awesome but my expectation is so
far beyond what I thought I was going to
be experiencing because I can still see
around me and then if I want to kind of
close off the world I can put on the
light blockers and you're having a whole
new experience so this is actually
really cool I can't wait to try this out
more so you can also hook up Bluetooth
headphones if you do have a pair of
headphones that you prefer to wear you
could also use those because obviously
this isn't going inside of your ears it
is kind of an outside kind of sound so
other people may be able to slightly
hear it but for the most part I was
pretty impressed how loud it actually
was and Jake over here wasn't even able
to really hear it at all like you could
hear a little bit right like just
slightly like five percent of what I
imagined yeah so he said it was probably
about five percent of what I was
actually hearing so if you are on a
plane or something like that and you
want to have a complete silence for your
seat neighbors I honestly don't think
that they would even be able to hear it
to be completely honest with you the
other thing that is kind of cool about
this is how low profile it is like if
you've ever put on any other VR headsets
like they're really big like that's not
something that you're gonna take on a
plane and the fact that you don't
actually have to charge the glasses
themselves that they are just operating
through whatever device you're using is
kind of cool so that's an extra thing
that you don't have to worry about
charging it just works I just want to be
in here
for always well my friends that was just
the first look of the unreal air and I
feel really bad that you guys aren't
able to experience what I'm experiencing
like I don't even know how to show you
what I'm seeing because it's just so
impressive how clear the video quality
is when I'm looking well thank you guys
so much for watching I'll put a link in
the description if you want to get more
information or to purchase the unreal
air this was such a cool experience and
I look forward to checking this out more
playing some games and of course
watching a ton of content if you guys
haven't already please subscribe and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and I'll see you guys in the
comments below bye
foreign
[Music]